è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in
un nuovo blog
ma prima di cominciare come al solito
iniziamo con la parte della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
valentina ragazzi questa è la prima fan
art della settimana che faccio vedere
proprio cioè che ce l'ho proprio io
fisicamente perché mi è stata consegnata
al games week end ragazzi sto paletto
c'è di tutto c'è la nutella che c'ha le
gambe non si sa perché c'è matt fiddes
addirittura viti ancora nedb other poi
ci sono io che sono sul podio di steve
poi c'è su motorie scrive l'afp insomma
è un qualcosa di epico grazie mille ti
meriti assolutamente rivincere la parte
della settimana ci tengo a precisare
comunque che nel week end non ho fatto
video perché era appunto alle slick e da
oggi si riparte comunque quindi
tranquilli ragazzi io non avevo mai
visto una cosa del genere in vita mia
mai non mi è mai successo ci avrei io
ero andato al torino comics l'anno
scorso già ad aprile avevo firmato 45
autografi perché comunque vada il mio
canale aveva 15 mila iscritti quindi va
bene agli inizi però ne avevo firmati
tre o quattro questa volta loro filmati
tre o quattromila c'è una cosa
impressioni ragazzina così incredibile
ho fatto non finivo pd far le foto di
fare gli autografi e stata un'esperienza
incredibile ragazzi vi ringrazio tutti
quanti perché è stata un'emozione ed è
stata destata una cosa incredibile poi
ho ballato su just dance in live sul
palco perché c'era lo stand di just
dance
all'inizio lo stand era vuoto saranno
due o tre persone una volta che ho
finito di ballare c'erano 500 davanti
allo stand tutti con le macchine
fotografiche perché mi avevate
riconosciuto quindi facevate le foto
nonostante mi sia stancato a fare due
miliardi di foto perché ho passato la
giornata a fare foto e autografi
nonostante questo ragazzino mi sono
divertito tantissimo e stata
un'esperienza incredibile nonostante le
foto e gli autografi eravate in un
casinò ad avere la mia maglietta cioè
una delle mie magliette nelle tante che
mette giù di solito ed è stato
incredibile vedere gente che andava in
giro con la mia maglietta ci riguardava
tipo cazzo alla mia maglietta non si
posso credere
ragazzi io veramente grazie fantasy è
stato fantastico e detto questo ragazzi
direi di passare allo scatto dei parchi
ragazzino non so se avete visto la foto
che recentemente pubblicato sulla pagina
di facebook
mettete mi piace la pagina di facebook
nel quale faccio vedere quanti pacchi mi
sono arrivati ragazzi io non mi stanno
più vi giuro non mi stanno più e quindi
ragazzi vista la mole di patti che che
ciò da aprire per questo episodio deciso
di aprirne caduto tutto ciò ragazzi
questi più grandi mi mette un attimo da
parte direi di partire con la scartare
il più piccolo fa vinceva vj our che
cazzo vuol dire ad da davide fans spacca
tutto
vabbè ragazzi non so che cosa intendesse
con spacca tutto comunque apriamo sto
pacco abbiamo dei giornali mi hai
inviato ho paura a vedere che cosa c'è
qui dentro ragazzino non ha idea c'è una
gnocca mi ha inviato una gli occhi
grazie mille
ho sempre sognato di scartare una gnocca
in un pacco fantasma è un pollo di non
posso chiederti cosa me ne faccio di un
pollo di gomma ragazzi ho sempre
considerato un polo di gomma cazzo è
fatta a guardare tra l'altro c'è anche
nella panart non sa cos'è pica che c'è
guardate che roba
questa è la parte che io ho fatto vedere
prima questo è il pollo di scribblenauts
è questo e questo è quello che manca
invece la varietà e la stessa cosa
comunque la cambiare dimenticato di
dirvi che alghe ismi coote ho preso una
cosa fantastica che è questa ragazzi il
simbolo di the sims che hanno tutti sim
in testa è fantastico
cioè io io appena l'ho visto me ne sono
innamorato detto devo averlo cazzo
ho fatto una cosa di due ore e mezza ma
alla fine l'ho preso quindi ragazzi vi
lancio una sfida nei commenti scrivetemi
una nazione che dovrebbe compiere un
team che io dovrei fare con questo in
testa e lo farà nel prossimo episodio
comunque ragazzi passiamo al prossimo
parco quello di grandezza media e poi
passiamo a quello più grande
raga stoppato a differenza degli altri e
leggerissimo non so che cazzo ma vi
giuro non ci posso credere
no ma fresco s fantastico questo è
fottutamente fantastico il film non ci
credo il pupazzo di scrivere note epico
ragazzi non dove cazzo hai preso ragazzi
io non so chi vi abbia inviato il
pupazzo di maxwell ma ma cazzo è il
miglior pupazzo che abbia ricevuto fino
adesso ha di sicuro non era quello di
cat marine poche parole lo metterò sulla
mensola perché davanti a tutti gli altri
perché il cazzo è fantastico fini
ragazzi viene di passare al terzo ed
ultimo fatto quello più grande
è duro ma i tagliare l'elastico con un
coltello perché mi avete fatto un kit
maioni stoffa non ne bastava già 13 e
finché fan art paul polly di gomma cioè
scrive market mario di stoffa l'erede
possiamo chiudere qui con lo scarto dei
bachi che il bello che lino altri 2
miliardi 20 volte più grossi anche se io
ho paura di vedere che il cazzo ci è
pari a quelle cose ma riscatterò nel
prossimo blog e quindi ragazzi fatto
questo dice vi passa rafa risponde fa vi
risponde perché non puoi lasciare alle
titanic con cat mario mio cuscino gli
umidi del culo mi riscaldo abbastanza
tanto freddo freddo le stelle
a presto certo è morto questo regalo ma
[ __ ] a quali risponde il secondo
te perchè ice si vedono più di noi umani
attira verità sono molto perplesso
riguardo a questo perché secondo me alla
fine l'insulto il classico insulto sei
un cesso
non è proprio un insulto perché comunque
se tu sei un cesso alla fine vedi più
fitti di chi te l'ha detto andrea
licitra dove lucca comics and games su
marte ma vi risponde provi anche fosse
una di quelle persone che ci rimane male
se una frase finisce come non te lo
patata
[Musica]
va bè ragazzi direi che però ci possiamo
concludere qui il blog veramente è stata
una cosa incredibile
vi ricordo soltanto che dato che la
prossima settimana c'è lucca comics and
games non sono sicuro se sabato domenica
riesco a far uscire video come questa
settimana qui perché appunto sono al
lucca comics and games ma comunque
comunque dalla prossima settimana si
riparte a fare video anche del weekend
come ho sempre fatto che io ci provo a
farli ci provo cioè nel senso ti faccio
prima per poi pubblicarli nel weekend se
ci riesco bene se non ci riesco cercate
di capirmi che sono andato al game freak
e a lucca comics e quindi e non essendo
a casa impossibile fare meglio con i
ragazzi se vi do è piaciuto come al
solito ha lasciato un commento vi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non
diviso trovato nella descrizione assenze
da kristi iscrivete venirci vediamo il
prossimo finito beh ragazzi